there is a local medical facility that
puts our seniors wellness at the center
of attention
here's more so let's talk about central
and who you guys are
introduce us so central is a network of
one-stop-shop
centers for our senior focus
primary care and we have eight locations
total in the las vegas valley
now you got us covered all across the
valley and what does center well mean
when people drive by what does that big
sign mean
so center well was originally named
partners in primary
care but has switched to centerville to
better capture our focus on wellness for
our senior patients
and you mentioned senior focused care
what does that mean to the community
see your focus means easier access to
appointment times
usually same day or the next day
appointments
and it also means shorter wait times in
our lobby area
and longer times with the provider so we
can get to know each other
so what other unique services do you
guys provide our local seniors
so for some of our senior patients they
get
lonely or they have financial struggles
some of them will have food and
securities and we provide
all that support as a team collaboration
wow and mentioning team here i know you
guys have a special
thing called care teams at your
facilities what does that consist of
a care team if you will you can think of
it as a football team as the provider
we're the quarterback
we run the plays we watch everything we
oversee everything but
there are other people such as the
clinical pharmacist that will go over
all their medications to see if there is
any interactions
um as i said there's a resource
coordinator for food insecurities
and things of that sort wow taking care
of our seniors i love that and i love
the football analogy that was good
doctors
where can people find centralized like
we said they're across the valley
so centaur you can go to seniorfocuslas
vegas.com
the website again is
seniorfocuslasvegas.com to find the most
convenient location for you
we have eight in the valley currently
and more to come
awesome and i understand that you are
accepting new patients
absolutely great great people are
you know still a little reluctant to
come into facilities
i know that it is the perfect time to
come in and see a doctor right
yes so for our patients who are 65 and
older we would like to see them
every three months just to make sure
everything's okay
to prevent them from going to the urgent
care or the er
um and for the annual wellness visit
it's important to have
once a year to go over everything from
head to toe
all your preventative screening and make
sure you're in tip-top shape
we have telehealth visits so they have a
smartphone or a tablet
you can do a video conference i know
some
patients may not have that and so we can
also do a telephone visit as well
call center well senior primary care at
702-766-4910 or visit
seniorfocuslasvegas.com